as you begin your day think about the
power of your mindset your mindset can
make or break your success remember that
failure is a part of the journey to
success and it's important to embrace it
as a learning opportunity don't let fear
hold you back from taking risks and
trying new things instead focus on your
goals believe in yourself and take
action Success is Not an overnight
achievement it requires hard work
persistence and resilience but if you
maintain a positive mindset and keep
pushing forward you will achieve your
goals so take a deep breath believe in
yourself and take the first step toward
your dreams